on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
happy bank holiday Monday I am Rosanna
Lockwood on uncensored tonight the
gloves are off by as the Phillips
Schofield drama rages on the disgraced
former star of this morning hitting back
at social media reports with toxic
culture on that show but as an
advertising boycott begins and questions
continue to be leveled at high ranking
Executives about who knew what how will
ITV find its way out of this crisis and
their Tick-Tock Terror mizzy who
appeared on this show with peers last
week's back in custody the pranksters
called the police's response to his
actions quite weak so will authorities
finally crack down on his Reckless
Behavior
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored oh it's
a bit of a Sprint that I've seen Pierce
do it before this is my chance Piers off
on holiday this week good to be with you
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored I am
Rosanna Locke we've got a great show up
for you and we will of course be talking
about Schofield the Scofield Saga the
this morning Saga my question about this
though is why why do we care so much
about this this story is it's sucked up
front pages it sucked up airtime
conversations for weeks now even at the
pub over the weekend where I live I was
asked about it all the time as somebody
working on TV oh do you have any gossip
do you have any gossip about Schofield
now look before I go on let me just
preface by saying this I am not making
any excuses for his behavior it does
look from this far completely abhorrent
nor am I denying the No Doubt terrible
and life-changing experience of the
young man at the center of all of this
we mustn't forget about that person and
of course there are systems of power and
toxicity in the world of Television that
are abused and they do need to be fixed
but in addition to all of this terrible
things are happening every day in our
lives and the world around us huge
consequential political and corrupt
things that affect ordinary people's
lives day in day out and instead of
focusing on those for a few days we've
been sucked into this morning television
melodrama so why do we care we're going
to try and bring some answers to this I
think it's because it represents the
death of a dream the happy smiling
Perfection of Holly and Phil look at
them there the LIE we've been sold for
years now it also represents a course of
darker seedious side to Showbiz one
where those in power can use their
influence to hoist young employees into
positions more quickly than is fair or
usual now schofield's lover was a runner
on this morning we'll be telling you a
bit more about runners in the business
but they tend to start out their careers
in that position fairly Junior within
the production side of things so why was
he then standing next to ITV Day times
managing director and the show's editor
while Holly and Phil accepted this award
in 2018 that's an odd workbook for
someone so Junior now as humans we are
of course all always grimly fascinated
to see the downfall of the Rich and
successful but do we feel better as a
result of all this do we take anything
away from it perhaps we learn to trust
ourselves and our instincts a little bit
better and to see a little bit more
clearly when we're being sold a
distraction packaged up as reality
because as we know the real world is
complex and it's sometimes really awful
but is where we have to exist and one
thing this show uncensored does is it
gives you the uncensored view of all of
that so let's get into it shall we
joining me here in the studio please say
Dr Mary kompinska who is a
psychotherapist specializing in
relationships and the entertainment
industry also Showbiz journalist Sarah
Louise Robertson and joining us down the
line former BBC head of Ethics arkel
Ahmed look thanks to all three of you
for joining Arco I will come out to you
very shortly but first let's start with
the ladies in the studio
um
coming to you first Sarah uh Sarah
Louise because this is a very busy time
for Showbiz journalists it has been
non-stop I'm sure for you commenting on
this given the timeline of events the
last few days and where we're at now
have there been any surprises to you
because a lot of people saying we knew
about a lot of this all along the
surprise is that Holly still seems to
think that she's going to have a job to
to come back to and that this morning is
still carrying on and think that they
can ride this out and and get through
this and that's what the surprise I
thought the show wouldn't have come back
today but it has and we saw today Alison
Hammond and Dermot say that they're
going to carry on fighting for the show
and there's obviously people there that
I know that work there who are very
lovely and I feel very sorry for all
those people whose jobs could be
possibly at Jeopardy right now and and
in Peril right now but I am surprised
that the show did come back the way that
it did today but they seem determined to
keep fighting on and to try and ride out
this absolutely huge Scandal but I've
never known such a dark day in itv's
history such a dark weekend shall I say
in itv's history then then this Scandal
Do you believe it was a toxic place to
work I've been told from people that
I've been speaking to over this weekend
former employees that have told me there
was a toxic culture that was going on
behind the scenes I was told that some
former employees were made to sign ndas
I have not yet put those allegations to
to YTV I'm just collating at the moment
evidence from from from former employees
that that were working there but there
seems to be the impression that I'm
getting for people that I've been
speaking to is that there was this toxic
culture and that's been verified by Dr
ransh Who came out over the weekend and
said that he had complained to ITV
Executives and bosses and that was why
he left the show a year ago because he
saw things that didn't sit right with
him let's go out to arkel then on that
on Dr Ranch because the comments that we
heard from this uh personality that
appeared on this morning for almost a
decade Arco he was saying uh that you
know part of his purview was looking at
diversity was look looking at ethics
this morning and he felt that whenever
he complained to the managers he wasn't
taken seriously enough and he was
effectively managed out talk to us from
your position your experience how common
that type of thing is
well I don't know if that's the case
with regards to Dr Ranch but obviously
we do know that that's how he feels I
mean ITV have said they did investigate
um his allegations when he when when he
brought them to them so you have to
actually take it on face value what
they've said what they've done actually
you know where it was right up whether
it was whether that actually happened in
the way that it should have been we
don't know now in terms of across
television yeah it's
I'm not saying it's really really common
but it can happen you can basically you
know you can complain you can be seen as
being a bit of a troublemaker and you
can be moved on and so that can happen
you know so what he's saying isn't
actually necessarily
far-fetched it's not the kind of thing
that I would say oh no that could not
have happened so it is possible but I
think on this instance we have to give
ITV the opportunity to actually lay out
in front of everybody what the
investigation did when he brought it to
their attention a couple of years ago
and then you know people well baby then
we can judge for ourselves what really
happened and at the moment it's what he
says on ITV say we investigated it but
didn't find that toxic culture of
bullying at the time so that the
question is how good was that
investigation yeah that we don't know
about that that is the question I would
be left with Arco from this and I myself
have worked in news organizations and
taken part in these types of
Investigations and I've seen them time
and again outside and internal and
sometimes you feel like they're not
doing enough they're protecting the
company more than they are the employees
I want to come to Dr Marie in the studio
about the topic of toxicity uh We've
mentioned it a few times but also the
psychology of some of the personalities
involved it because that's what you
special specializing just give me a
little bit of a kind of overview of what
you've noted about the way Schofield has
handled all of this well he becomes a
little bit of a boy doesn't he he has
never owned up even when he was saying
that I've come out as being gay he
handed it over to Holly to read out for
him so he's never really taken ownership
and he's been forced into this situation
suddenly and he's totally out of his
depths because forced into a bit he you
know he's made the situation no he has
he's made it but it doesn't mean that
people know how to handle it and this is
what happens he's won this mask I mean
the theater group that he was a patron
of was called two-faced and that's him
you know he he has one face for media
and one face for his real life I would
go so far I'll say a lot of people in
media do I personally and quite
different in my real life to how I am on
television some of this hair and makeup
it's like a suit of armor that you put
on but it's one thing to just be a
slightly more casual person in real life
and another thing entirely to be living
a double life as you say so talk to me a
little bit about the psychology of how
you lied your family for that long how
you lie to your is it true that he
really did lie to his family you know I
would have thought that his wife knew
but accepted that he was living a
different life women often know that
there's something else going on but
don't want to mention it Lord don't want
to acknowledge it and that's not a bad
thing because they want to keep the
family together
but you know they come to some sort of
arrangement I've known other people that
leave their wives and announce their gay
and go off into a gay relationship and
the family has accommodated that during
that period of time so there's one story
that he's been giving the public but
what I'm interested in is most of the
public know and people at home know and
they need to take more accountability
for that knowledge themselves so sort of
perpetuating that line taking the public
for fools well yeah but the public
aren't fools but they don't know it
within themselves whether they can
actually address it what do I do I know
this is wrong I know he's wrong but how
do I deal with it and they do rely on
the institution the workplace to deal
with this and if the workplace doesn't
deal with it everybody is left to look
like fools it's a model for everyone
Sarah you want you want to add something
to that but yeah the public won't be
taken for fools and they can tell aren't
they the figures when Philip did that
big coming out he had everybody's
sympathy everyone's supported him said
how Brave and and how wonderful that he
came on that sofa but what we know now
is that that was with Sherrod because he
was asked at the time is there anything
that prompted this have you ever had a
relationship with a man and he lied he's
now admitted to lying and that he lied
and said oh no I've not done anything so
he lied not just to to his wife and
family but he lied to his fans and to
the public and to the show as well
although obviously the discrepancy which
is going on now is how much did the show
really know from behind the scenes but
what he put out to the public he asked
us to believe in him and and to believe
in in what he was saying and we trusted
this person we trusted his voice when he
was leading the show he was seen as a
safe Pair of Hands someone that when he
told us something during the pandemic we
were listening to him and believing in
him and trusting him and now he comes
back and says it was like a politician
it was all an act it was all a ruse a
key word you brought up those trusts I
want to come back to our kill on this
because this is why ethics exists in any
organization but particularly media and
organizations news organizations and the
like and to talk to us a little bit
about breach of ethics of this nature
Scofield calling his actions quote
unwise but not illegal but as we all
know this documentation when you work at
most companies that have code of
conducts do you think he overstepped
well I can only speak I'm speaking on a
purely personal capacity I think that it
you know the fact of the matter is this
that actually he what he said is
completely correct unwise relationship
now if you look at some of the kind of
things that we've seen about the you
know the runner we've talked about maybe
we may go on to talk about that later on
you know I've been a runner we've all
been Runners when we started out in our
career uh you know there is an issue
about whether or not somebody who's a
runner who's at a very basic entry level
of of work should that person have a ba
in a relationship with somebody who is a
star or the orbit or the series editor
or whatever somebody who's in charge or
in charge of their Destiny for that
matter and I think when you're in that
situation it doesn't it's probably it is
it is an unethical relationship
particularly when it's as ITV have said
that they investigated this and he said
obviously that he wasn't in a
relationship people around them said
that they didn't know anything about the
relationship the reality is it's very
hard for anyone to take anything on face
value if you have individuals who are
lying because he's I've admitted
obviously it's like that's not me we can
say that clearly he's admitted to lying
so the fact of the matter is it becomes
really hard to believe many of the
things that he may say about this or
about anything else and then of course
as our other men people have mentioned
we then get into the situation about who
knew what and what things then hushed up
Etc what I would say is there is so much
transparency involved in all of this now
and an investigation that's not getting
around it investigations will be
happening if they happen before it'll
definitely be happening again and those
investigations will should be very
transparent and I think the people I
know some of the people involved in the
senior executive of ITV they've got a
track record in investigating things and
making very big decisions as and when
they need to be made it is
come to Dr Maria on this and just talk
briefly about this before we run out of
time but that power Dynamic even if it
is consenting adults as they are saying
in a situation but obviously the huge
age difference is a huge seniority
difference I mean how did you begin to
deal with that as a psychoanalyst
psychologist yeah I just think he is
totally out of order you have to as a
person who is in leadership you have to
take responsibility of your actions and
I think we're in a culture that's
beginning to recognize that individuals
have to take responsibility for their
actions and he hasn't and he's being
forced to and it's good that's why
everybody's intrigued by this it is like
mythology Greek mythology in our in our
homes at the moment and mythology was
based on people of power losing their
power and what happens when they're
caught and caught out and he's been
caught out and we all want to know how
he's going to deal with it and how the
whole institution the media institution
is going to deal with it and in turn the
public and the court of public opinion
will certainly have a lot to say Sarah
letters and with you quickly if you uh
Holly well I'll move on to Holly in a
second but I just want to say as well in
the power Dynamic the person in question
was only 15. he was a teenage boy when
he first met Phillip Schofield what on
Earth would a growing man I have to talk
to a 15 year old boy about
and why would he want to keep in contact
with the 15 year old boy well he's a
predator well
I'm saying there's something that sits
uncomfortable I think with people it
certainly sits uncomfortably with me so
I just wanted to point that out uh yeah
yo it's hard to put that and I will find
out it's alleged obviously a lot of this
and quote unwise but not illegal those
are the facts that we have at the moment
I want to thank you all very much for
joining us for this conversation Sarah
Dr Maria and Uncle Alma joining us down
the line as well some really good
insights from you all uncensored next to
night is the law tough enough to stop a
new generation of tick-tock pranksters
we'll be debating that next stick around
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Piers Morgan unscented
meet Rosanna Lockwood you might notice
but change that to me in peace I'm
standing in all week pleasure to be with
you now we are revisiting this story
that Piers did this fascinating
interview or last week I'm sure you saw
it tick tock man is Missy he's the young
man who performs pranks on the general
public before uploading them to social
media he is very much back in trouble
again remanded in custody at the weekend
for reportedly breaching a court order
not to film members of the public
without their consent this is the video
here of his arrest now this new arrest
took place just a few days after Missy
whose real name by the way is bukhari
bronzagaro he took part in an exclusive
and fiery interview with peers on this
very show in this very Studio he gave us
then some insight into why he continues
to create havoc you've only got a tiny
fine today no deterrent to you
whatsoever you don't show any real
remorse you don't really care UK laws
are weak simple as the UK laws are weak
simple as and that's not my fault
which begs the question does Missy have
a point
you can all squeak simple as should the
criminal justice system deal with young
offenders harsher and earlier than it
currently does or is it fit for purpose
joining me to debate all of this mizzy's
friend fellow Tick Tock star Billy the
goat who spoke to the prankster in the
days leading up to his arrest also
joining us there from Norway of all
places criminal Barrister Casey Chris
door and here in the studio I'm joined
by talk TV contributor Esther Krakow
thanks so much Esther I'll come back to
you shortly but first let's get over to
Billy uh shall we because Billy's mate
he's the mate of mizzy so you were able
to talk to us first hand about your
knowledge of mizzy
um last menu is remanded back in custody
again have you checked in with Missy and
how he's doing
[Music]
communicated with I've spoken to him and
I feel like my interview kind of brought
a different side of him there like
pierces one daily I'm trying to say so
that's why I'm that's why I might have
come across to the outside world that
were mates but I wouldn't say what makes
but definitely someone that like
definitely someone that don't waste any
harm on them all right you saw that
interview did with peers then um what
did you make of it because I know it
went pretty viral a lot of people saw it
did you get much reaction uh from people
you knew how did they think Missy
performed
if I'm being honest with you I feel like
the interview went exactly how I
expected it to go to like I don't really
know what anyone anyone expected like he
brought like a prankster that's like 18
on like one of the big like a like a
professional TV show like I didn't
expect them to actually have any proper
dialogue if I'm being honest with you
and another thing is like I don't know I
feel like with there's a certain way you
talk to people I'm trying to say like
you don't you don't speak to everyone
the same way like obviously I understand
the players are his own interviewing
style but I feel like sometimes
according to who you're interviewing you
kind of have to change up a little bit
and me personally I don't think he
handled the music thing well but then
again I don't really blame him because
Missy Missy is a lot to handle for being
honest but yeah yeah I did meet Missy in
the makeup room he is a character look I
appears isn't here to defend himself he
has got his own interviewing style this
is his show and he's kind enough to put
me in the seat tonight uh to speak to
you but let's just talk about the
punishment side of it because that's
what we're going to talk to our next
guests about as well uh Missy said that
the UK laws were weak and I just want to
go back to Billy uh do you think Mrs
right to say they're weak because he's
currently remanded in custody
obviously that's his opinion me
personally like I've never had any
accounts with the system like I wouldn't
be able to give a firsthand opinion
whether the week or not but obviously
the public opinion was that lacker I
think it was like 350 pound finally got
and the public opinion is that that is
like a bit of a like a get off but at
the same time when you really look at
the situation like I don't I don't know
I would I wouldn't say that it's weak
but then again it depends which angle
you want to look at it though in the
very much I'm going to look at it
because realistic is like I don't know
what the exact laws I don't know what
the punishment is are for each run
realistically so I couldn't say whether
the week or not to business I don't know
so uh coming to Esther in the studio the
the
the idea behind is that mizzy feels uh
somehow licensed to behave the way he
does because the laws are so weak I mean
that is what he said to peers you and I
were watching it from the studio he was
saying let the UK laws are weak I'm just
gonna have my fun I don't care if it's
negative or positive I just want
engagement so do we need to change the
UK system
um yes obviously but I think it's it's a
combination of two different things this
is clearly an example of extremely bad
parenting and there's only so much that
the penal system can actually Rectify in
that situation this is a kid who is
hungry for attention and that's what the
social media era we're living in um is
clearly feeding him so he has no
boundaries obviously the deterrent
should have been more than a 350 pound
fine I'm assuming the judge thought that
he didn't actually have that money to
pay it or something I don't know but I
think that's clearly very weak he's
terrorizing the public
um but it is bad parenting I often said
you know there's a reason why he's
stealing old women's puppies and jumping
on uh conservative Jewish men's backs
he's not going to you know tall black
men in Tottenham because he knows he
probably won't go home with all his
teeth in his mouth
um so clearly it's it's a discipline
issue it's something that falls on his
parents quite squarely on the shoulders
but it's also a penal system issue and I
think we need to address both he's
obviously an example of what it happens
when parenting goes very very wrong and
look we don't have Missy here to talk
about his parents uh Billy says he's not
close enough to know uh Missy's family
but on the penal system side things
let's get over to Chris adore Casey
joining us from Norway and the reason
that you're in Norway Chris to my
understanding is to learn a little bit
about how they deal with youth crime
there so why do they get it better than
here
well because first of all um when they
when you're talking about young
teenagers they don't criminalize young
teenagers in Norway at all and indeed
there are other countries that don't
criminalize people until they're 18
years of age and the reason for that is
because as I think mizzy demonstrated
pretty clearly in his interview with
peers
um young people and particularly young
men don't really mature properly until
they're into their 20s and and the level
of immaturity that you could see in that
interview I think was clear for all to
see and frankly um when I watched Mrs
interview I thought that the whole thing
was him playing around with Piers Morgan
rather than the other way around it
rather looked like he had kind of um
managed to get one over on Piers quite a
lot of that interview because ultimately
Mrs objective is very clear isn't it to
get as much attention as he can and
that's not dissimilar I would have would
suggest from television presenters and
media stars of every different
generation and every age it is about
attention and seeking clearly some of
the things you've done are um you know
are are very unpleasant to the people
involved but you know we've had these
kind of prank TV shows on television for
years and years and years will remember
in the 80s there were programs where
people were had their cars crushed and
they had no idea what was going on and
they didn't consent to that in the first
place and and you know so so is it a
genre that is only available to
middle-aged white presenters because it
does feel a little bit like it we've got
an 18 year old who's capturing a lot of
attention a lot about audience um and
and really I I think it's all a storm in
a teacup yeah it will Chris I'm
interested you saying that because I'm
with you on a lot of TV personalities
pushing the envelope as far as they can
to generate engagement not caring about
negativity let's just get attention but
there's one thing doing that pushing the
envelope there's another thing
illegality we've got some videos of
mesozantics we can remind viewers of
breaking into people's houses stealing
people's dogs uh leap frogging over
people on the street you know just
pretty bad anti-social uh Behavior stuff
but also some actual sort of pretty bad
criminal acts you've got walking into
people's houses and things like that you
know this is what has landed him in a
lot of trouble with police so could you
really say this is on a par Chris uh you
know with I don't know Jeremy Beadle and
people back in the day
it's exactly On a par with it because
the people who were subject of those
pranks didn't get have any consent uh
their friends set them up or their
families set them up for it and and so I
don't I honestly don't see the
difference it's it's a situation where
people are taking advantage of other
people to create content which many many
young people in particular on Tick Tock
find funny and so I just think you know
he's 18 years of old old he's quite
immature when you talk about criminal
acts I mean you know it's on the margins
of criminality some of this stuff as
opposed to anything that would be
particularly serious I suspect
eventually he'll grow out of it
um as most young people do provided
they're not locked up in prison because
this is really where Norway have got it
right they don't lock people up in
prison and they don't look um at young
people up in prison unless they've done
something really bad a really extreme
violence uh and long-term criminality
and and if you lock teenagers up the one
thing you guarantee is when they come
out of custody as this young man will
I'm sure within days or a few weeks when
they come out of custody they are more
criminalized than when they went in so
if we're going to have this idea that we
need to lock people up for longer and
get tough and all this stuff you end up
with more crime in society as opposed to
the sort of peaceful place we have here
in Oslo where there's a 3 000 pound
barbecue it's not even locked up they
just leave it here on the side of the uh
on the side of the water because no
one's going to steal it and why is that
it's not because they're getting tough
and cracking down on young offenders
it's because they do the opposite yeah
you're not going to see that and the
Streets of London Manchester Birmingham
anywhere around the UK really that three
thousand pound bob I want to come back
to Billy uh while we've got you Billy
and some of those points that Chris made
about entertainment this is just
entertainment it's just Tick Tock you
know do you think it's okay what mizzy
is doing to these people for
entertainment
nah definitely not obviously if you
watch the interview are done with him
like I made it clear that I don't can do
anything done but at the same time
though like that to answer your question
I really you know it's not okay but then
to add some context I feel like similar
to what he was saying before like we are
in an everywhere it's all about shock
factors all about attention even though
I do um internet and I do make content
myself I did understand that there is
repercussions with just doing anything
and everything for Visa I'm trying to
say to you I'm busy being a promise so
me personally life I also like I don't
know advise any up and coming content
creators I would definitely say that
don't you feel the need to like do
whatever comes to your mind that's going
to get infused like actually think of
black a legacy and try build a
sustainable internet City like running
people's hearts and taking books that's
not sustainable that's like you can only
do that one to two three times and then
there's nothing you can do after that
like I'm trying to say yeah I think it's
actually very smart it isn't sustainable
at all it's one and done uh the Esther
will give you the final word on this
um the solution to this you know we're
hearing Chris say you don't like people
up unnecessarily if it's not too
criminal I mean could you agree with
that what's the solution for someone
like Missy it depends on what you define
as two criminal I'm sure if that was his
mother that he had a young group of men
breaking into a house uh he would feel a
bit more different differently about
what is too criminal uh the reality is
there needs to be a deterrent in place
because what you see happening now is
because something like this is getting
busy the attention that he wants and the
attention that he craves you push the
envelope and more people are
incentivized to push the envelope today
they're entering people's houses
tomorrow they're doing something even
more and generally terrifying the
general public I made the point that if
he was in a different country if it was
in the US for instance they would
actually have the right to shoot him
um so you know how far is too far before
someone seriously gets hurt it's not
just about the fact that you don't think
that what they've done is particularly
criminal it's also about the fact that
how Justified would someone be to react
in a way that is generally in you know
in pursuit of preserving their own life
as they see you know as being threatened
and so I think it's something to not
take lightly and I think people that do
take it lightly don't understand the
wise The Wider societal context and the
issue here with just bad parenting as
well we're going to have another
conversation about policing at the end
of the show so do stick around uh
because we're going to talk a little bit
more about the Met police and some
things they've been up to uh next to
that though on uncensored as Philips go
feel to fair with a younger male
colleague has revealed we asked could
ITV lose Millions when the stock market
reopens tomorrow we also remind you that
this shop is Morgan uncensored is
shortlisted for an NTA award we want to
remind you to go ahead and vote for That
interview for this show for Piers to get
another gong to out to his cabinets who
stick around we'll be debating next
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
hello there happy bank holiday Monday
this is Piers Morgan uncensored me
Rosanna Lockwood City and peers's seat
tonight the shocking story of Phillip
schofield's affair with a younger male
colleague that's what we're talking
about again now because it has caused a
media storm in this country but not only
that the Scandal could actually cost ITV
the company that we all have known and
love obviously since we were children
many of us decades all we're going to be
talking all about it it's cost that
company tens of millions of pounds now
this shows biggest sponsor car dealer
Arnold Clark has announced it is ending
its existing deal with the channel the
first one we know about to go in a
statement the car dealer saying quote
our existing sponsorship of this morning
will end this Autumn as planned and
according to insiders at this morning
guests are now refusing to even appear
on the show and it doesn't stop there
ITV executives are apparently bracing
themselves for a potential dramatic
share price drop tomorrow when the
market reopens it's a publicly rated
company at ITV and it's been a bank
holiday weekend so we're only going to
see the effects of what has happened
with Schofield from the weekend when the
Market's open tomorrow now to discuss
all of this I'm joined by the manager to
the Stars Jonathan Charlotte Jonathan
thanks so much for making time to speak
to us um look there's a lot of angles we
want to talk about this from with you
but for starters for the viewers at home
that don't work in television because we
can all get caught up in this bubble
can't we living in TV working in TV uh
that people we just assume people know
what a runner is and how serious this is
and the type of abuse of power that went
on at this morning with Schofield so
from your perspective from managing
talent in Television over the years
um how shocked are you by these
Revelations
and shots but do remember I first heard
this in 2020 because of the National
Television Awards the young man in
question was openly telling people about
the relationship that it's not only come
out now in in 2023 is hugely surprising
because it's been I wouldn't even use
the words otherwise Open Secret but Open
Secret will imply a secret it was
commonly known since 2020 since January
2020 because the young man in question
openly told everybody
that's absolutely extraordinary and
that's your first-hand account uh
obviously we have the facts from ITV and
the statements that they've given us
throughout and the statements from Holly
and the statements from Philip as well
that is we've blurred out the um the
main character in question because of
course this is you know a case of abuse
of power but we have seen his pictures
been shared around and things you must
remember there is this young man at the
center of this all this is a really
disturbing State of Affairs and ITV
saying we're deeply disappointed by the
admissions of Deceit that were made by
Schofield Schofield now coming out today
and saying you know oh my ex colleagues
are slamming this morning but this
morning was actually a great show to
work on he's saying there's just so what
I would say is this morning is a great
show to work on
um people are slamming Phillips
Schofield a lot of people have many many
happy memories of this morning over the
years it's been a joyous show it's been
a successful show it's been a show
that's campaigned for very important
matter but even last week you had Alison
Hammond born in the prime minister to
account you know and and it's fantastic
you have that environment where an
ordinary person if you like as opposed
to a sophisticated interviewer can speak
to the Prime Minister and hold them to
account so I think they've changed the
law
massive terrible things have happened to
the world and this morning have brought
attention to that I mustn't forget it's
35 years old and one of the most
important daytime shows in British
television is it time for a reboot a
reformat is that sort of two person
couple on the sofa format tired and dead
does it need to be remade and how much
damage does all this do to ITV it's not
gonna tank the network is it well you've
asked a lot of questions so let me try
and deal a few each one individually the
two-person format works all over the
world in many different countries at
many different times of day right now as
we talk on ITV and to Deca hosting
um a big TV show you know in the morning
I morning shows around the world have
two people presenting them you have
double acts presenting Primetime
entertainment shows so I don't think the
suggestion that a two-person fronting a
team has gone its past Itself by date
stands up I mean ITV is a master
successful company with Incredible
programs they're getting incredible
ratings so yes this this morning has had
a negative life on it in the last few
weeks but that shouldn't take away from
the fact that ITV you know is an
incredible platform for anyone including
the man who seek you occupied tonight
who had a massive success for many years
at ITV so you know ITV is a great
globally recognized successful company
yeah I don't think we've got if we do
we'll bring it up his uh tweets because
he's been tweeting quite a lot about
this well he's actually been talked
about with regards to this a lot in the
last few days he's found himself having
to respond to those people saying well
you're talking an awful lot about
leaving ITV but the circumstances of his
departure from ITV were of course very
different let me give you an example and
we talk about ITV one of the most
successful Global franchises in recent
years Downton Abbey ITV so yes you can
talk about Coronation Street ITV
um so there are many amazing things
about ITV and that's important to
remember so in terms of managing the
brand the recovery from this if you were
acting on behalf of them I don't believe
you I haven't disclosed that you are uh
how would you go about saying this does
somebody need to go at the top at
management
I don't think someone needs to go at the
top because I think the people at the
top were lied to I mean what I talked
about that this young man and by the way
people are quite right not to reference
his name because you've got to remember
he was a Youngster and it was a complete
Beauty Supply by someone higher up so
you know he might not even realize he's
been a vulnerable victim yet but this
young man has been a victim of a much
older person and the people around
Phillips Schofield would have known what
was going on but absolutely the people
at the top were probably deceived
because when they say they didn't know I
believe them because they're honest
people with integrity and I knowing the
people at the very top of ITV I
genuinely believe if they had genuinely
known they would have acted so I think
the people lowered down did not send the
message upwards when asked and what
about Holly his co-hosts very difficult
position to be and I've co-hosted shows
before when you're that comfortable with
someone that close to someone you show a
lot of time you're getting up early in
the morning and you know a lot about
each other's lives how deceived does she
feel
well I suspect she feels immensely
deceived because yes you can't and he
got from a TV friendships and not real
friendships and of course I know they
enjoy personal friendships with family
holidays but I doubt but at Schofield
brought the young boy a young man on the
family holiday so when she asked him was
it true and he said no it wasn't true
what was she to believe I mean this lady
is equally a victim of deception now of
course in the coming weeks the people
prove differently that's a whole nother
conversation but what I read she must go
I don't quite see why because I also
know the public still love her I mean
she's a hugely talented presenter lots
of experience you know many different
kinds of programs under her belt so I
see no reason why a successful
television career won't continue I would
like to think that Not Guilty By
Association exactly but the court of a
public opinion can be very strong as we
know Jonathan Charlotte thank you so
much for making time to talk to us with
me here in the studio to continue this
conversation times radio host Henry
bonsu because Henry uh terminology have
appeared on ITV a number of times number
of these years warning view with Holly
and Phil Phil and Rochelle and I've had
a very pleasant experience as Giles
Brunswick who often does it as well and
does Vanessa Fels in the morning but we
float in we float out we're treated very
well you know given coffee giving quests
and you know we're treated nicely by the
presenters as well and from what I could
see it seemed to be a fairly happy ship
but we don't know uh whether bodies are
buried so we've got no idea what it's
really like to work on the show and
spent 8 or 10 hours in that particular
Studio or in that environment over at
ITV or over in West London wherever it's
based now when we're talking about this
you and I we're talking about the
croissants and the cars I'd like to say
there are no croissants on this show but
you know to the average view back home
they must be thinking those you know
hoity-toity TV people and is that why
people get so
um outraged because they're giving up
hours of their time to be entertained by
these people every day and they're loyal
to yourself there is a two-way process
two-way process I mean the reason why I
don't know what the figures are at the
moment but the reason why it's the best
part of a million people watching each
morning is because they find a reason to
watch you know television is the friend
for a lot of people and there's a deep
epidemic of loneliness in this country
so their best friend is that box in the
corner of their room and so they build
up a relationship especially over years
which is one of the reasons why if they
feel they've been deceived they react so
viciously and so strongly and they cease
to see say Phillip Schofield even as a
human being at this point do so do you
think Holly Will emerge from this
unscathed that Jonathan was saying she's
talented she's hard working she was
nothing but a faithful loyal co-anchor
and a good friend to scope with all
these years well most of the people who
are attacking her tend to seem to be uh
from the industry there's certain people
and and looked at and checked their
profile and some of them have got a
little bit of a connection with the
industry or people who just love piling
on but I suspect that if she can emerge
with Integrity if nothing emerges that
shows that she did know and that she
lied as well then she'll be fine because
I mean she's still in the finest flush
of her career as Jonathan said she's
very versatile she's very very pleasant
on camera she can do a whole range of
shows and that she isn't the person who
has sinned here is she no absolutely
look Henry do stick around Esther's
going to be joining us back at the
studio you're going to be our pack for
this evening we've got some really fun
stories for the viewers coming up next
but we'll be starting something a little
more serious footage emerging of a woman
drag tagged by a female met officer that
was the female officers dragged by the
thief a male colleague struggling to
deal with it filming it instead we've
got questions have the Met police gone
soft on criminals going to be debating
that next
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
coming up on the talk this morning in
meltdown as Philip Schofield says people
have a grudge against him denying the
show is toxic outrage over four MPS who
claimed hundreds of pounds of driving
fines on expenses and if climate change
keeps you up at Night Don't Fear because
our eco-conscious King has turned down
the heating on his private pool by a few
degrees that's all at nine o'clock
[Music]
well that is the talk coming up next
first though we're going to get to our
pack for the evening the views of our
uncensored panelists joining me in the
studio talk TV contributor Esther Krakow
and the journalist sometimes radio host
Henry bonsu both of us joining still on
the show you've given us some good
insights so foreign Esther I did say
we'd come back to policing so let's
start here we will have a bit more fun I
promise but this one is interesting this
is a video uh this week let's show our
viewers while we talk about what is
happening here Britain's police
Federation has blasted the London and
met police off this video's release a
suspected sweet Thief dragged a female
cop by her hair and threw her into a
wall in an attack that has sparked
ridicule on social media so what you're
seeing there is a thief actually
swinging a met police officer around by
a ponytail allegedly uh meanwhile you've
got her male colleague the Met police
officer's colleague filminess and saying
madame Madam please Madam this was
happening in willesden North uh North
London uh just this week so it has led
us to question here on the show is
policing too soft in this country now
it's a theme we keep coming back to and
you know I tend to have a bit more
sympathy for our police I think they do
a very very tough job Indeed and they
get put in some very difficult positions
but for me for this one guys I mean just
watching one of the police officers her
colleague holding a camera and filming
it how would you feel less if you were
swung around by a ponytail and I was
filming it well certainly anyway um I'm
built differently so she wouldn't have
had a favorite time um but I think that
the her colleague filmed it for evidence
um so I understand that I I have a very
controversial opinion on this because I
actually saw a video of two female
police officers trying to arrest uh this
man put him in handcuffs and he
literally elbowed one in the face
punched the other one and ran off
um and then I questioned why anyone
thought it was a good idea to put two
female officers on on patrol at night I
just thought you know the logistics of
it was completely crazy I think
Frontline find police officers and all
police officers obviously put themselves
in danger should be men and should be
men of a certain style and the reason
why I say this is because I think the
standards of our policing has really
fallen down it's not just about having
you know men they have to be men that
are physically fit how many metropolitan
police officers do we see with pot
bellies where did you draw the line then
should any uh people in the Army be men
soldiers well if they're from if they're
in on the front line yeah they should
wow Henry agree I really don't agree
with that I mean I think what we saw in
that video was a guy was clearly
incompetent he probably feared for his
own safety let alone that of his
colleague I don't think that we can
scale up from that to say that most
police officers are incompetent and
terrified and nervous and don't know how
to do the job I mean just check out
YouTube You'll see plenty of officers
who given the chance of Stephen they do
are mob-handed and sometimes we get a
problem with too many officers who look
to react first instead of educate you
know explain and then enforce I think as
the Metropolitan Police Commissioner has
said previously there's an awful lot of
offices who should not be in the job but
it doesn't have the means and the web
with all to get rid of them and that is
one of the skill sets they lack to be
able to do the physical side of the job
well that's because Fitness testing has
gone through the roof I mean the fact
the the physical fitness of a lot of our
offices is just not up to par I mean
watching them chase criminals is
actually quite funny but also there is a
deterrent element to having strong
physically fit intimidating looking men
as police
give you an example if I as a woman call
the police because God forbid I was
being you know abused by my partner in a
domestic violence situation and two
female officers came at the door I'm
sorry I would not feel as safe have you
ever watched mixed martial arts in UFC I
love what kind of female boxers
who are stronger I'm stronger than most
women I know I pull dance right men are
stronger than women I've been born
dancing for four years I could I could I
could take on a lot of you know
moderately sizes
an explanation before you get to so
there's but there's the enforcement part
of it also matters just as much as the
other part and I'm sorry but fat not fit
men and I'm sorry women shouldn't be I
don't think we've got enough fit men in
this country to staff well the police
but moving on talking of deterrence we
want to show our viewers this video we
talk a lot on this show about climate
activism Anita Eco activists and how
police deal with them check out this
this is in Sweden this was during the
version of their version of Strictly
Come Dancing their finale you see an
eagle Act was taken out by a camera
there that is a camera what we call a
jib a crane and the camera absolutely
socks this activist over the head now
we're familiar with these eco-activists
now pouring orange powder of themselves
these guys they were talking about
restoring Wetlands they said we like to
dance but the climate's more important
is this how we should be dealing with it
do you think that was accidental Henry I
think it was accidental I mean I didn't
dance up and down with Glee like you did
relaxing the problem is that these guys
what they're doing is counter I think
when we look at polls most people agree
that my mid climate change is happening
and government has to do something about
it Net Zero targets I think we have to
get there by 2050 and some people think
it should be brought forward let's wait
and see whether or not we elect
politicians who will actually make that
happen but if you look at what's going
on around the world it's not going to be
by little things that our government
does that will change things it's going
to be you know China India the USA the
cops and people watch what's going to
happen this summer we're going to get to
40 degrees again look at what happens in
other countries we have flooding in
parts of the world which are not
supposed to flood so I think people have
been persuaded but running up and down
and throwing orange powder is not going
to change the needle at all yeah and
look I'm with Henry on this Esther you
know climate change is very real and we
do need to face it on front but is this
the way to do with these activists that
people find so irritating I think
they've got a message certainly not um I
mean they're nuisances um but I do think
that's a beautiful bit of karma there
um I do think the that's uh nature works
the balance is in order this is
fantastic and we've got to say that we
do respect the right to protest you know
we're not spoiler brother no I don't
respect the right to terrorize the
public
a lot of these people gluing yourself to
the M25 you're putting people's lives at
risk now what they did specifically
didn't necessarily put people's lives at
risk but I think on on in the grand
scheme
I'm all right thank you very much cool
off with the idea of ice cream Henry
said you know we'll get to 40 degrees
this summer unfortunately we probably
will and ice creams obviously in this
country we love to eat 99s and ice cream
with a flake in the top this story now
that Cadbury's flakes are too crumbly to
be used in 99 cones we went out to speak
to an ice cream seller and this is what
he said
German chocolate very delicious and
never been broken on the 99 place
yeah it's it's hard it's a bit
it's very bright
it's probably better
we are used to the idea of chocolate
bars getting smaller as we get older but
crumblier difficult to handle these are
german-made ones he mentioned in the
video
there is a British version but I believe
they're actually manufactured in Egypt
do take one of these if you can and just
test them out because this just proves
the sizes and everything
flake this flake the British version
doesn't actually taste of chocolate so
I'm not even going to eat it it tastes
like dirt it is incredibly crumbly yeah
crumbly and a bit bitter not very nice
well you say the German version isn't
nice but this is the one that the ice
cream vendors actually prefer Henry at
the moment because they say it is more
stable in a 99.
this doesn't taste like chocolate it
tastes like a boot but these are the
important things for us to consider here
on this show whether or not flakes are
too crumbly and I'll show you what I'm
just about possible to eat this but
things change life moves on we're gonna
have German flakes in our ice cream
cones this summer when it is 40 degrees
unfortunately Henry Esther it's been
fantastic having in the studio difficult
to talk through earthquake that is it
for me I'll be back here tomorrow on Biz
Morgan uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign